sommet sous très haute sécurité à madrid
dix mille agents des forces de l'ordre
ont été mobilisés parmi les participants
a annoncé le président américain joe
biden son homologue français emmanuel
macron ou encore les chefs des
gouvernements allemand et britannique au
coeur de la réunion la guerre en ukraine
et la menace russe le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky participera
d'ailleurs en visioconférence
nous allons nous mettre d'accord sur un
programme d'assistance globale renforcée
à l'ukraine
cela va inclure des livraisons massives
pour aider le pays dans des domaines
comme les communications sur les
systèmes anti grenelle pétrole
à plus long terme nous aiderons
l'ukraine à faire la transition d'un
équipement militaire datant de l'ère
soviétique
un équipement moderne de type autant et
nous l'aiderons à renforcer encore ses
institutions de défense et de sécurité
jugent tous parmi les autres décisions
annoncées le renforcement des
groupements tactiques dans la partie
orientale de l'alliance notamment dans
les pays baltes frontaliers de la russie
ou de son allié biélorusse estonie
lettonie lituanie par ailleurs jens
stoltenberg l'a annoncé ce lundi
nous allons transformer la force de
l'action de l'otan et augmenter le
nombre de nos forces au niveau de
préparation pour le porter bien le
dessus de 300 m
les dirigeants de l'otan vont aussi
pressé la turquie de lever son veto aux
candidatures de la suède et de la
finlande à l'organisation en quart à
leur reproche d'être complaisant envers
des groupes kurdes qu'elle considère
comme terroriste
des négociations auront lieu en présence
de redjep tayyip erdogan dès mardi à
madrid
là d'urgence est arrivé